l'armée américaine plie bagage ce samedi
les derniers gi's déployés en
afghanistan entament leur départ en
laissant derrière eux un pays en proie à
ses vieux démons
les combats font rage entre forces de
sécurité afghanes et talibans
les insurgés font une démonstration de
force et tente de gagner du terrain en
vue des négociations avec le
gouvernement qui doivent reprendre la mi
mai à istanbul
nul ne sait encore si et comment les
talibans peuvent revenir au pouvoir
mais cette éventualité inquiète de
nombreux afghans surtout les femmes avec
la présence des forces américaines et de
la coalition leurs conditions que
s'était quelque peu amélioré certaines
occupe désormais un emploi ou ont dû
ouvrir leur propre commerce des droits
qu'elles craignent de perdre si nous
avons l'assurance d'avoir la paix dans
notre pays et la sécurité pour notre
peuple
nous porterons le vide jab mais à
condition que l'on ne nous impose pas de
restrictions et que nous puissions
travailler et étudier
nous ne voulons pas de l'ancien
afghanistan je n'ai pas vu de talibans
mais je les crains je n'ai pas obtenu ce
que j'ai fais maintenant facilement j'ai
travaillé très dur pour cela
car s'il revenait vraiment un jour et ne
nous permettaient pas de travail et je
devrais retourner en iran et vivre comme
une migrante sans lobo a shadow's tale
les femmes afghanes auraient d'ailleurs
bien plus à perdre que leur emploi tout
ou presque leur était interdit du temps
des talibans travaillez donc mais aussi
être en contact direct avec des hommes
sortir sans burqa par l'effort faire du
vélo
l'éducation des filles étaient
proscrites même le propre nom des femmes
n'apparaissait pas sur leurs actes de
naissance de décès ou sur leurs pierres
tombales et en cas de faute
les exécutions sommaires n'était pas
rare alors à kaboul les femmes élues au
parlement rejette l'éventualité d'un
retour des talibans
les talibans ne crois pas à la
possibilité de vivre dans un
environnement pacifique en afghanistan
nous ne pouvons pas accepter une
situation dont l'avenir post paix en
afghanistan
les femmes mourront de nouveau sous la
coupe des talibans et où nous resteront
assis à regarder
nous devons prouver qu'il n'y a pas de
place pour le mode 2
l'idéologie des talibans dans le nouvel
afghanistan et au 100 m et 200 m
à l'heure actuelle la pianiste en compte
trois femmes ministres plus d'un quart
de femmes parlementaires 2,5 millions de
filles scolarisées et 19 pour cent des
travailleurs afghans sont des
travailleuses une situation mise en
péril par le départ des 9600 militaires
américains et de la coalition le droit
des femmes était pourtant l'un des seuls
bienfaits à inscrire au bilan de ces
vingt années de présence des etats-unis
et de leurs alliés